meps approved the reform of the eu's  farm policy which will come into force  in 2023  at least 25 percent of direct payments  to eu countries will have to go towards  environmentally friendly practices  forty percent of medicinal products  marketed in the eu are made in non-eu  countries parliament discussed how to  improve medicine access and make the eu  less dependent on third countries  meps adopted the eu's budget for 2022  they secured an additional  479.1 million euros for health youth and  climate action  six member states haven't yet ratified  the istanbul convention which commits  countries to preventing and fighting  violence against women  meps asked why progress has stalled in  those countries  17.9 million europeans moved to another  eu country in 2019. parliament asked the  commission to speed up the launch of a  european social security pass to  facilitate the movement of workers  between countries  [Music]